welcome to manhood I'm here to make you
all men in here you separate from the
girls the first thing you must do is to
make a vow to never see another chick
flick again let's check your tear it up
shut the door
next thing you must do is take your
brain that's right here this rules your
work right here's where you'll be making
most of your decisions so now I want you
to have no idea what shirt goes with
what pair of pants you have no concept
the color because if you are wearing the
ones that are ribbed for her pleasure
you got that you were not responsible
for remember any special days you don't
know when you had your first cancer what
song you first thanks to you just going
to be able to use all power tools he was
usually the fix anything and everything
now there's now that you can't think
nothing you can put together your power
tools not broom and dustpan
you're a man not a housewife there's
nothing on the cart you can't fix
you must be able change the tire filter
sparkly belt and the oil and you can't
figure it out you keep looking at the
engine to tell you do you know how to
get wherever you're going well assist of
a map against agent anymore police
officer do a built-in GPS you're a man
you must know sports you are the most
intelligent being on the planet
therefore you must be able to talk about
every single detail sports you will know
every player on every team in the
American the necklace the NFL the NBA
at the end each other you must also
remember every statistic associated with
these fighters all these teams that lose
knowing what college they would do what
diamond plate they're over here rip what
team they're 22 in each and every team
has ever ever played for and here which
they were training you also you know who
was training with who they train for
total amount
earning and designer training after the
train you will also need to be able to
calculate and discuss whether or not you
strength was off the world fair NBA
Supergirl or Stanley Cup championship
and in if you earn up to the task you go
to the kitchen and bake me some cookies
any questions all right and let's go out
there and find us a [ __ ]